fox has gone left they've gone woke
we're clearly calling them out for
Tucker is a great voice for
conservatives across the country he
doesn't have the platform anymore will
you weigh in on Fox's decision to fire
probably one of the more conservative
voices most important voices in America
absolutely I think it was devastating to
our first amendment Eric I see it as a
very serious problem our first amendment
is Free Speech but it's also freedom of
press and when a gigantic Media company
like Fox News fires their number one uh
Tucker Carlson not for him doing
anything wrong not because his ratings
were bad but they literally fired him
because they came to the woke mob now
that's completely untrue
Tucker Carlson caused a
multi-hundred million if not
multi-billion dollar problem for Fox
News Fox News made this decision based
on money